Houser Gomez - beer and you are most
welcome - how much of a bro are you well
today we're gonna find out basically I
found a bunch of quizzes online that
test us your bro skills or your whatever
and I wanted to see myself how good I
could pass on them so feel free to try
this along and leave a link in the
description I sure hope I qualify that'd
be embarrassing
where is beautify from I don't know how
am I supposed to know that you could
literally Google this um I just realize
that you can cheat next question is
pretty easy question what is Petey pyres
real name Toby Naruto Turner why narrow
toe why put Naruto in them beautify duh
haha Felix Arvid Oh she'll buy or
Fishkin Fishkin wolf ad medial strim ah
it's Felix our video shot Gary go what
is purifies favorite color
I never said what my favorite color is
how the hell would they know this
alright it's either ooh red or this
green or Blair I'm sorry what Blair
blue or yellow oh sorry
yellow um I guess blue what's your
favorite cut blue what is purify his
favorite food I never said this either
how the [ __ ] would they know this
chicken is my favorite alrighty next
question how old is PewDiePie 24 what
year was 45 warning you could just
calculate what was the point of this
question who is PewDiePie married to
it's a trick question he's not married
where is she from
but I'm not married here's a little tip
in this quiz if any of the questions and
with duh that's the right answer
so Italy duh what pet does peopIe have
and what is its name I have a pet called
Maya and I have a pet called Edgar Oh
both C and D mmmm that's a tricky one
what kind of games does poop I play the
most often funny slash pointless games I
would say that what game is your
favorite that beautify plays how can you
get this right which is the right answer
I would have to pick it that's probably
one of my favorite of these games which
PewDiePie character is your favorite
this one has no effect on your results
what that what then what's the point I
didn't know I had this many Oh far shot
if we got a fossa
now for the final question are you a
true bro but I thought the point of the
test was to test maybe smiley face I
lied this is the final question you lied
to me haha I I honestly I guess 28
that's it closes one barrel if I can
pass this Chris but what did I answer
wrong yes if you did this place tell me
if you managed to be a bro I'm gonna be
amazed if you pull it off
Oh what what who is your YouTube
boyfriend
alright we're gonna do this one as well
what's your favorite movie I like chick
flicks and dramas Mean Girls horror
movies definitely say your crush asked
you out of prom which dress would you
most likely wear uh-huh yeah I would
look great in this one yep that's a
little too trashy for me who's your
favorite youtuber why would you add why
would you what isn't the point of the
quiz to find out why would you just ask
me I'll save you some time next time all
right
here's for the final moment I shipped
myself with my shelf wait I shipped
myself with my shelf that's that's one
thing to do I guess no I [ __ ] myself for
myself I don't [ __ ] myself a message I
shipped myself with myself there's a
story here on how we met let's skip to
the juicy part ever since I first met
Felix at VidCon we'd both grown very
close and we ended up hanging out with
each other whenever we had the chance
it was then Felix began to stroke my
cheek before kissing me very pie can't I
can't nope nope I can't I cannot do this
but Felix looked down at me with a
seducing seductive stare in his ocean
blue / green eyes third ocean blue yeah
right creating awkward silence after a
moment or so he then asked you want to
be my girlfriend
Oh Felix I can't believe you never asked
we both smiled as I felt the atmosphere
between us beginning to G we were gonna
make love I failed
tremendously at the bro test but
apparently I [ __ ] myself myself I ship
myself with ya let me know your
brother's results hope you enjoyed this
video thanks for hanging out with me
today on
had a busy day so I had to do something
a little bit easier today hope you don't
mind but thank you for liking this video
I really appreciate it bros and as
always stay awesome bros brophy